[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رغم الهو في الموقف بين حركه حماس
واسرائيل بشان الصيغه الملائمه لوقف اطلاق
النار وتبادل الاسرى لم ينفض وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني بلينكن يديه من
عمليه التفاوض ومن فرصها في التواصل الى
التوصل الى تحقيق الهدف منها بلينكن الذي
التقى قيادات اسرائيليه عده قال انه لا
يزال هناك مكان لاتفاق بين اسرائيل وحماس
مضيفا في اشاره مثيره للانتباه ان رد حماس
وان كان مرفوضا في جوانب منه الا انه مع
ذلك يوفر ما وصفه بارضيه للتفاوض في
المقابل اسهب رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بنيامين نتنياهو في انتقاد الرد الذي
تقدمت به حركه حماس دون ان يغلق فيما يبدو
باب التفاوض نافيا ان تكون حكومته قد
التزمت باي وعود بشان الصفقه التي
اقترحتها حماس نتنياهو قال كذلك ان تحقيق
الاهداف الاسرائيليه في الحرب مساله اشهر
ولا رجعت عن الانتصار فيها ياتي ذلك في
وقت اكدت فيه حركه حماس ان وفدا منها اتجه
الى القاهره لاستكمال عمليه التفاوض
الراميه للتوصل الى اتفاق لوقف الحرب
واطلاق متبادل للاسرى مع اسرائيل ونقلت
وكاله فرونس بريس عن مسؤول مقرب من الحركه
القول ان حماس منفتحه على مفاوضات اضافيه
لوقف اطلاق
النار نرحب بضيفي هنا في هذه الحلقه من
الخليل الدكتور بلال الشوبكي رئيس قسم
العلوم السياسيه بجامعه الخليل ومن واشنطن
شارز دان الدبلوماسي السابق في الخارجيه
الامريكيه نبدا بالسيد
دان الوزير بلينكن بدا
متفائلا بخصوص امكانيه التوصل الى صفقه
رغم
التحفظات
الاسرائيليه برايك هل من مبرر لمثل هذا
التفاؤل نعم اعتقد ان هناك مبرر للتفاؤل
ان وفد حماس في القاهره يتحدث الان عن
امكانيه الوصول الى وقف لاطلاق النار وهذا
يثبت ان الابواب لم تغلق بشكل كامل من قبل
كلا الطرفين رئيس مجلس الوزراء نتنياهو
قال انه
يرفض المعروض ولكنه اضاف بناء على ما
شاهدناه حتى الان اي انه يتوقع امورا
اضافيه وبالتالي هذا مشجع للاداره
الامريكيه بشكل كبير واعتقد ان الاداره
سوف تستمر في جهودها الدبلوماسيه وللعمل
مع الاطراف الثالثه وخصوصا دوله قطر ومصر
بالاضافه الى الحديث مع الاسرائيليين
للحفاظ على هذا الزخم ولو كان قليلا صحيح
سيد دان ان
نتنياهو لم يقل
بالحرف انه يرفض العرض ولكن ما عدده من
مثالب يعني ضمنيا انه لا يقبل ما
عرض في الحقيقه النقطه الاساسيه التي
يرفضها
الاسرائيليون هي وقف العمليه العسكريه حتى
هزيمه حماس بغض النظر عن ما يعنيه ذلك عدد
كبير من المراقبين يرون ان حماس لا يمكن
القضاء عليها لربما هذا الهدف لا يمكن ان
يحقق بالاضافه الى ذلك هو لا يود ان يوافق
على وقف مفتوح لاطلاق النار او وقف نهائي
لاطلاق النار برايه هذا ياتي بالفائده
لحماس هاتان النقطتان الشائك تان لان حماس
عبرت ايضا عن هذا الرد وهناك مجال للتفاوض
يتعين على المتفاوضين ان يحاولوا ان
يتوصلوا الى اتفاق يرضي الطرفين ولكن هناك
سبيل للمضي قدما ولو كان كانت المساحه
محدوده والجميع وخصوصا الولايات المتحده
والسيد بلينكن ولا شك سوف يعود الى
المنطقه وياتي بشيء جديد في انتظار هذه
العوده المثير ل للانتباه دكتور بلال
الشوبكي ان ان بلينكن عندما يقول هناك
مكان لاتفاق وبان اداره بايدن ستواصل
العمل دون كلل للتوصل الى اتفاق وقال هذا
الكلام بعد ان التقى قيادات سياسيه
وعسكريه وامنيه اسرائيليه هل تعتقد ان
لكلامه ارضيه معينه جعلته يتشجع ليقول
هذا بدون ادنى شك يعني هذا كان واضحا حتى
قبل الوصول الى تلابيب بمعنى انه ربما كان
هناك تواصل فعال ما بين الاداره الامريكيه
وما بين القيادات الاسرائيليه بخصوص هذه
المرحله تحديدا بمعنى انه تنامت الى اذهان
الامريكيين قناعه قد بدات بتشكل قبل
اسابيع وهو ان وجود حركه حماس واستمرارها
حتى هذه اللحظه ومستنده على حتى تصريحات
من قبل قياده الاركان الاسرائيليه بان
حركه حماس قد شرعت في ترميم قوتها المدنيه
والشرطيه في شمال قطاع غزه كلها امر تشير
الى تعزيز قناعه يعني تشكلت لدى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بان مسار المفاوضات مع
حركه حماس لم يعد مسارا احتماليا وانما
مسارا حتميا وهذا الامر قد عبر عنه كيربي
سابقا والان يقوده يعني بلينكن في هذه
الجوله من الزيارات لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
وبالتالي مضافا الى القناعه الامريكيه
هناك ايضا قناعات اسرائيليه تغيرت بمعنى
انه بيني جانس اصبح اكثر وضوحا في الحديث
عن ضروره اعاده ترتيب اولويات الحرب
الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو بالرغم من كل
هذا الخطاب العالي السقفي الذي قدمه الى
انه لم يغلق الباب امام المفاوضات الشارع
الاسرائيلي نسبه الاستطلاعات نسبه اولئك
الذين يؤيدوا الذهاب الى صفقه اصبحت
اغلبيه 51% بالرغم من انها يعني ما زالت
في طور التشكل الا ان 51% هي نسبه تشجع
الكثير من الاطراف على الحديث بصوت اعلى
عن ضروره الذهاب الى صفقه ال الكثير من
التقارير التي قدمت من مراكز نخبوي في
اسرائيليه في اسرائيل تشير الى
ان المستوى السياسي اسرائيلي لم يعد قادرا
على تحقيق ادراك الانتصار في الذهنيه
الاسرائيليه بمعنى انه سرد الانجازات من
قبل الناطقين العسكريين والناطقين
السياسيين بخصوص العمليه العسكريه في قطاع
غزه لم يعد مقنعا في هذه المرحله وبالتالي
لابد من الذهاب الى مفاوضات حتى لا نقول
ان ان تفاؤل بلنك هو
مطلق الكتور بلال الشوبكي هو اشار بان
هناك امور غير مقبوله فيما قدمته حماس
ولكنه لم يحددها يعني هل لديك اي تصور لما
يمكن ان يكون غير مقبول امريكيا وبالتالي
اكيد سيكون غير مقبول
اسرائيليا وحتى لو كانت شروط حماس ادنى من
تلك التي وضعتها سيكون التصريح الامريكي
والاسرائيلي بذات الشان هذه جزء من
الادوات التفاوضيه في اي عمليه تفاوضيه
انه لا يمكن لاي من الاطراف ان يعلن
موافقته المبدئيه والاوليه بشكل كامل عن
كل ما قدم من قبل من اي اي من الاطراف
التفاوضيه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
هذه المعادله ليست وسيطا ما زالت هي شريك
ل لاسرائيل في كل هذه العمليه التفاوضيه
وفي كل العمليات العسكريه لكن بالذهاب
مباشره الى صلب السؤال المساله الجوهريه
هي التخوف من اي امرين الامر الاول هو وقف
اطلاق النار الدائم بمعنى انتهاء الحرب
وهذه ليست فقط هزيمه لاسرائيل وانما هزيمه
لحلفاء اسرائيل الذين تسارعوا من اجل
دعمها في بدايه الحرب وحتى هذه اللحظه لكن
المساله الاخ اخطر بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان الملاحظات التي
قدمتها حركه حماس لم تقدمها بصفتها فصيلا
عسكريا يقوم بعمليه عمليه عسكريه داخل
قطاع غزه وانما بصفتها شريكا فلسطينيا في
ضروره الحديث عن حق الفلسطينين في تقرير
المصير اخر ما كانت تتمناه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان تجد نفسها تتدارس
ورقه مقدمه او عليها ملاحظات من حركه حماس
يشار فيها بالاضافه الى وقف اطلاق النار
وتبادل الا وما الى ذلك من قضايا ترتبت في
مرحله ما بعد الحرب الى قضايا سابقه لهذه
الحرب مرتبطه بحق الفلسطينيين في تقرير
المصير وحقهم في دوله وضروره وقف السياسات
التي قدمت من قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
الضفه الغربيه والقدس نعم هو استكمالا
لهذا الافق السياسي الذي تشير اليه نسال
السيد تشارلز دان اليوم بلينكن اشار الى
او بالاحرى جدد التزام واشنطن بالامن
والسلام الدائمين
وبضرورة في المنطقه كما قال ودوله
فلسطينيه مستقله ان يكرر مثل هذا الكلام
في حين ان كل الحديث الان هو فقط عن مجرد
صفقه لتبادل الاسرى هل هو اشاره الى ان كل
ما يجري طبعا له افق سياسي يجب ان ينظر
اليه ب انتباه
كبير نعم بالفعل وهذا موقف الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الذي بدا يت
منذ اسابيع يجب ان يكون هناك افق سياسي
للدوله الفلسطينيه انا متاكد من ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا ترى
بالضروره ان حماس تؤدي دورا اساسيا
وقياديا في هذا المستقبل لربما اصلاحات
تتم على مستوى السلطه الفلسطينيه وتعزز
هذه السلطه الفلسطينيه وبالتالي تعزز
الدوله الفلسطينيه من خلال انتخابات في
مرحله معينه وتؤدي دورا اساسيا هذا وبكل
وضوح في جوهر السياسه الامريكيه رئيس مجلس
الوزراء نتنياهو كان في غايه الوضوح هو لا
يرى دوله فلسطينيه قائمه للحياه او قابله
للحياه اذا ما شكلت تهديدا امنيا لدوله
اسرائيل ولكن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
سوف تبقي على هذا الموضوع كراكيز لمقاربات
ولكن كما يقال الشيطان يكمن في التفاصيل
وطبعا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تعرف
شكل الضغوط التي توضع على اسرائيل من اجل
المضي قدما باتجاه حل الدولتين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تركز الان على شكل من
اشكال الاتفاق وبكل بساطه على الامد
القريب نتحدث عن شكل تبادل السجناء
بالاضافه الى المساعدات الانسانيه التي
تعرقلها اسرائيل خصوصا في الاجزاء
الشماليه من قطاع غزه هذا مجال يمكن
التوصل الى بعض الاتفاق فيه وتامل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انه سوف يؤدي
الى تقدم في مجالات اخرى مما قاله بلينكن
ايضا سيد دان نقلا عن عن اي
اي وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه ي دعو ت
احرنوت انه قال لنتنياهو ولقيادات
العسكريه والامنيه بان ليس كل سكان غزه هم
من الموالين لحماس وبانه لن ينسى ما بقي
حيا الاف الاطفال والعائلات الذين ذهبوا
ضحايا في الغارات الاسرائيليه هل هذه
النغمه يمكن ان يكون لها دلاله معينه في
سياق الحديث الان عن عن سبقه يجري الخوض
فيها في الحقيقه هذا امر ممكن واسرائيل
يبدو انها تتبع السياسه التي تقضي
بتطبيق العقيده المرتبطه بلبنان اي الرد
غير المتناسب من خلال قصف يؤدي الى تدمير
كبير على مستوى الشعب وعلى البنى التحتيه
وذلك لتالي الناس ضد حزب الله في لبنان
على سبيل المثال وضد حماس في قطاع غزه
ولكن المشكله هي ان المؤشرات تشير الى ان
هذه السياسه فاشله ان شعبيه حماس وفقا
لاستطلاعات الراي ارتفعت في قطاع غزه وفي
الضفه الغربيه وبالتالي هذه العقيده لا
تؤتي اكلها بالنسبه الى الاسرائيليين
لربما في مرحله ما يمكن ان توجه
الانتقادات الى حماس ولكننا لم نصل الى
هذه المرحله بعد لكن بالعوده الى الرد
الاسرائيلي دكتور بلال الشوبك اليوم يجتمع
او هذا المساء ربما بالاحرى سيجتمع مجلس
الحرب ليبت في الموقف ما يتعلق في بهذه
الصفقه والرد على ما جاء في ورقه حماس
ولكن جلنت مثلا على سبيل المثال وزير
الحرب الاسرائيليه الاسرائيليه قال
بان
وثيقه حماس صيغه لتر رفض من قبل اسرائيل
بتقديرك ما هي الاشياء المحرجه فعلا في
هذه الورقه كما سربت على الاقل الاعلام
مما يجعل جلنت يقول هذا
الكلام بالنسبه لاسرائيل يعني مساله يعني
وقف اطلاق النار او ان يكون هناك ضمانات
لوقف اطلاق نار دائم بمعنى تجريد اسرائيل
من التلويح بامكانيه الاستمرار في العمليه
العسكريه وهذا ما يعني يتناقض مع كل
التصريحات التي قدمت من جالانت من بنيامين
نتنياهو حول ضرور الاستمرار في هذه
العمليه لانه حتى هذه اللحظه يعني اخر
خطاب لبنيامين نتنياهو وخطاب لجنتي تحدثوا
فيه عن ان الانتصار لابد ان يكون قادم
بمعنى يحيل الموضوع الى المستقبل وبما ان
الموضوع محال الى المستقبل ولم يتحقق حتى
هذه اللحظه القول بانه حركه حماس تريد وضع
مثل هذا الشرط وقف اطلاق النار الدائم
معناها تجريد اسرائيل من امكانيه المحاج
امام المجتمع الاسرائيلي اقصد الحكومه
الاسرائيلي بكل مكوناتها ان هناك انتصار
يمكن ان يحقق وبالتالي سيصبح الجميع في
دائره تساؤل امام كل المؤسسات الرقابيه
والبرلمانيه الاسرائيليه بالاضافه الى
المجتمع الاسرائيلي مضافا الى هذا الموضوع
من الاشياء الاساسيه يعني انا كنت اذكر
ونحن نناقش في بدايه الحرب وفي هذا
البرنامج لماذا تقوم اسرائيل بكل هذه
العمليات ضد المدنيين الفلسطينيين في قطاع
غزه جزء من القراءات كانت ان اسرائيل تريد
خلق قاعده جماهيريه في قطاع غزه لافضه
ورافضه للفصائل الفلسطينيه التي تتبنى
نهجا موافقا لنهج حركه حماس وعلى راسها
حركه حماس التي تتبنى العمل العسكري ضد
اسرائيل وبالتالي حين تقدم حركه حماس على
وضع احدى الملاحظات التي تتطلب ان يكون
هناك معونات عاجله من بينها تامين مساكن
للفلسطينيين بشكل كبير جدا يح يعني يخفف
من الازمه الانسانيه هناك وهنا ايضا
محاوله لتجريد اسرائيل من هذه الورقه لانه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واسرائيل لم
يعول فقط على العمليه العسكريه ومفعولها
الاني وانما كان التعويل ايضا على مرحله
ما بعد الحرب بخلق بيئه اجتماع
مناوئه للحركات الفلسطينيه المقاومه وهذا
مما يصب في مصلحه اسرائيل وهم يعملوا بناء
على هذا الموضوع يعني عمليات اعلاميه
مضنيه تقوم بها منذ منتصف هذا الحرب ضد
الفلسطينين في قطاع غزه يحاولوا زرع هذه
الافكار من خلال وسائل اعلام من خلال نشر
منشورات من خلال ارسال رسائل نقطيه كل هذه
الامور تشير الى ان اسرائيل فعلا تتعامل
مع هذا الموضوع بحساسيه هي تريد ادخال
المعونات بالقطاره وهي تريد يعني استخ دام
هذا الملف ملف المعونات واعاده الاعمار
كجزء من ادوات الابتزاز السياسي لحركه
حماس لسنوات طويله وليس فقط لحركه حماس
لاي جهه يمكن ان تكون في موقع الامر داخل
قطاع غزه هذا من الامور الحساسه بالاضافه
الى مواضيع طرحتها حركه حماس خارج نطاق
قطاع غزه وهذا مما يعتبر من الخطوط
الحمراء بالنسبه لاسرائيل لانه جزء من
اهداف اسرائيل في هذه الحرب هي تفكيك ما
سمي بوحده الساحات وحركه حماس تريد ان
تقول ان هذه الحرب في في قطاع غزه لم تكن
حربا فقط من اجل قطاع غزه وانما من اجل
قضايا مرتبطه بالقدس والمستوطنات وما الى
ذلك من سياسات اسرائيليه تمارس في هذه
المنطقه نعم في انتظار سيد دان في انتظار
صدور موقف رسمي من مجلس الحرب اذا ما اتخذ
مثل هذا الموقف اذا كانت اسرائيل رسميا لم
ترفض الى حد الان الورقه ال ورقه حماس
وبلينك متفائل لكن لديه بعض التحفظات ما
الذي يمكن ان يدخل من تحسينات بين قوسين
لتكون هذه الورقه مقبوله اسرائيليا
ومقبوله بالكامل
امريكيا اعتقد ان اسرائيل تسعى على الارجح
ان حماس ستتخلى عن موقفها القاضي بضروره
بقائها في السلطه بعد انتهاء الحرب في
قطاع غزه هذا اولا على الارجح اسرائيل
تسعى الى ان تقول حماس انها تقبل بشكل من
اشكال
الترتيبات التي لا تؤدي بالضروره الى وقف
دائم لاطلاق النار اعتقد انهم يسعون الى
تحقيق بعض التقدم في مجال الرهائن وهذا
امر لا شك فيه بالنسبه الى الصيغه لاطلاق
سراح الرهائن والتي لا تطلب من اسرائيل
اطلاق سراح كل السجناء الفلسطينيين ونتحدث
هنا عن حوالي 8000 سجين فلسطيني وفقا لطلب
حماس اذا هذه هي الامور التي يمكن ان ينظر
بها مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي عن كثب لمعرفه
ما اذا كان هناك بعض التغييرات ولو كانت
طفيفه يمكن اطفائها على هذه الورقه بعد
طبعا الحديث بين وفدي حماس مع الاخرين في
القاهره ولكن الامر مبهم حتى الان سيد دان
اليوم في صحيفه هاردز مقال للصحفي
الاسرائيلي الشهير جدعون ليفي بعنوان
تحرير 1500 اسير ليس كارثه وليس ثمنا
مؤلما ماذا يقول في هذا المقال هنا انا
اقتبس يقول تحرير الاسرى ووقف الحرب
سيكونان امرا جيدا بالنسبه الى حماس ويمكن
ايضا ان يكون جيدا بالنسبه الى اسرائيل في
جميع الاحوال يمكن ان يكون البديل اسوا
كثيرا بالنسبه لاسرائيل هل تعتقد فعلا بان
ربما ليس امام اسرائيل صيغه افضل مما يمكن
ان يكون عرض عليها
الان هذا الامر يتوقف على ما تسعى اليه
اسرائيل اذا ما كانت تسعى حقا الى القضاء
الكامل على حماس عدد كبير من المراقبين
بما في ذلك انا شخصيا انهم يتحدون يتحدثون
يتحدثون عفوا عن دمار وتدبير كامل لقطاع
غزه والبنى التحتيه الى اخره هذا بالتالي
لن يؤدي الى قبول اسرائيلي ولكن اذا ما
كانوا يتحدثون عن صيغه تسعى من خلالها
اسرائيل الى اطلاق سراح الرهائن يمكن
التوصل الى الصيغه اذا كل الرهائن الاحياء
130 مقابل 1500 سجين فلسطيني هو جزء
تقليدي في عمليه تبادل السجناء والرهائن
بين اسرائيل وحماس قد يكون ذلك مقبولا
واذا ما لم يتم التوصل الى تعديلات بهذا
الشان لربما تكون الحرب طويله بالتحديد
دكتور بلال الشوبكي ربما ها اننا نتابع
الاخبار بما يجعل هذا الموضوع يعني في في
صلب المعركه الانتخابيه الامريكيه عندما
ياتي دونالد ترامب الرئيس السابق والمرشح
المرجح للحزب الجمهوري يقول لم يكن من
الممكن ان تتعرض اسرائيل لهذا الهجوم
الفظيع لو ولا اداره
بايدن قصه اداره بايدن او عوده اداره
ترامب هل تعتقد بان هذا الامر سيكون ايضا
ضمن الحسابات الاسرائيليه وهي تناقش ما
عرضته
حماس نعم على الاقل ضمن حسابات اليمين
الاسرائيلي يعني كان هناك تصريح من قبل
بنك فير لا يختلف كثيرا من حيث الجوهر عن
تصريح دونالد ترامب الذي تحدث عن هذه
الحرب وما الات هذه الحرب بمعنى ان
اسرائيل اك ان خساره اداره بايدن او خساره
بايدن للانتخابات لا تعتبر يعني خساره
كبيره لاسرائيل بل لا تعتبر خساره على
الاطلاق بحكم ان البدائل الممكنه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه افضل بكثير
على الاقل للتيار الذي يقود يعني اسرائيل
في هذه المرحله وربما استاذ محمد ان الذي
يدفع اداره بايدن للحديث بنبره مختلفه
وخصوصا في مؤتمر الدوحه على لسان بلينكن
هو جزء مما يجري الان في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بمعنى انه ليست فقط عباره عن
قناعه تشكلت لدى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بانه حماس يعني لم تنتهي
والجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات معها مساله
حتميه وانما ايضا الى ان اداره بايدن كانت
تظن في مرحله ما ان انه سيكون هناك فجوه
زمنيه ما بين انتهاء الحرب والتصويت في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بما يمكن جزء
من الناخبين الامريكيين الذين امتعوا من
سياسه اداره بايدن تجاه قطاع غزه ان
يتناسوا هذا الموضوع وان يكون بامكان
الحمله الانتخابيه لاداره بايدن ترميم
الاضرار التي لحقت في هذه الاداره نتاجا
لسياسه التماهي مع حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
خصوصا في الشهر الاول من الحرب على قطاع
غزه الان العمل يعني بشكل متسارع من قبل
الاداره الامريكيه من اجل فرض وقائع جديده
والوصول الى هدنه وان كنت تذكر معي يعني
استخدم بلينكن مصطلح جديد ربما وهو الهدنه
الممتده بمعنى انه لا يريد ان يستفز
اسرائيل بالقول ان هناك انهاء للحرب ويريد
ان يوصل رسائل طمانه الى الفلسطينيين
وتحديدا الى حركه حماس باننا لا نتحدث عن
وقف اطلاق نار مؤقت كما كان في الهدنه
الاولى او الهدنه السابقه التي كانت في في
بدايه هذه الحرب لذلك ما يجري حقيقه الان
هو جزء من اداره الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ليس فقط لما يجري الان في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وما يجري في قطاع غزه وانما
جزء من ادارتهم لما يجري داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لانه هذا تحدي ايضا
لاداره بايدن الذي لم يت لا يتصرف الان
فقط بصفته رئيسا للبيت الابيض وانما بصفته
مرشحا انتخابات قادمه الاكيد سيد دان بان
لا وجود على الاقل وفق التصريحات المعلنه
في واشنطن وفي تل ابيب لا وجود لود خاص
بين نتنياهو وبايدن شخصيا يكفي ما يقوله
كل واحد عن عن الاخر هل هناك خوف من ان
غياب هذا الود قد يجعل نتنياهو يصعد
الموقف اكثر هو في مؤتمره الصحفي البارحه
اكد على ضروره التمسك بما يسميه النص
الكامل القضاء الكامل على حركه حماس
استعاده المحتجزين بالقوه يعني نفس الكلام
الى درجه ان
اليوم احد المعلقين السياسيين لصحيفه
هاردز هو اوري مزاف قال واضح يبدو ان
نتنياهو سيضحي
بالمخطوبه لا تتم كما كما تريدها
واشنطن
من الواضح ان العلاقه بين بايدن ونتنياهو
متوتره لم تكن كذلك دائما في الماضي كان
لديهما علاقه جيده على المستوى الشخصي
عندما كان بايدن نائبا للرئيس وايضا عضوا
في مجلس الشيوخ ولكن نتنياهو رفض بشكل
قاطع كل الصيغ التي تقدمت بها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لوضع حد لهذه الحرب
ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه والحديث عن
الافق السياسي كل ذلك ادى الى ازكا التوتر
والمشكله هي ان السيد نتنياهو يستخدم هذا
التوتر لكي يظهر للداخل الاسرائيلي ان
باستطاعته ان يقف في وجه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لتعزيز شعبيته في الداخل
الاسرائيلي نعم هذه العلاقه الشخصيه مما
لا شك فيه انها سوف تعقد القادم بالنسبه
الى التفاوض ودعم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لاسرائيل وبالتالي هذه مشكله
كبرى تعليق سريع بالنسبه الى ما قاله
الرئيس السابق ترامب الحقيقه هي انه ايام
اداره ترامب
الفلسطينيون تركوا بشكل كامل لقد صادق
بشكل كامل على كل اجراءات اسرائيل بما في
ذلك المستوطنات والقدس
والجولان الى اخره وبالتالي برايي الشخصي
هذا الهجوم وهذا النزاع الحالي جزئيا اتى
بسبب اداره ترامب وافعال اداره ترامب على
عكس ما يدعيه الرئيس السابق وهو طريقه
تقليديه له للتعبير عن هذه الامور ولكن
سيد دان عندما يعني السؤال المشروع ربما
اذا كانت اداره بايدن لا تستطيع ان تفرض
او تقنع نتنياهو لا بزياده ادخال
المساعدات لا بتقليل عدد الاصابات من
المدنيين لا
بصفقه لتبادل الاسرى والمحتل زين كيف يمكن
لها ان تقنعها
بصفقه متكامله سياسيه فيها دوله فلسطينيه
فيها تفكيك المستوطنات فيها استعاده اراضي
يعني القصه تبدو معقده جدا وربما ايضا حتى
مضلله لست متاكدا من ان الاداره الامريكيه
باستطاعتها ان تفعل ذلك الاداره يمكنها ان
تقوم
بالممكن من اجل الحفاظ على الامن وعلى
العلاقه الامنيه والسياسيه الحاليه
وهذه
المشاكل تسبب بها السياسات التي ادت الى
التخلي عن الانشطه الدبلوماسيه وايضا
الدمار الذي نشهده الان في قطاع غزه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يمكن ان تؤشر
بضروره رفع منسوب الضغط الاسرائيلي لا
يتعين عليها ان تحمي اسرائيل عند كل مفترق
على مستوى الامم المتحده يمكن الاداره ان
تقول انها لن تدعم الزياده ب 16 مليار
دولار امريكي زياده المساعدات العسكريه
لاسرائيل للمضي قدما في هذه الحرب في قطاع
غزه يمكنها القيام بالكثير في هذا النطاق
لربما قد يؤدي ذلك الى التاثير على
العلاقه ولكن على اي حال ليس بالضروره ان
يؤدي ذلك الى تاثير اساسي لتحريك اسرائيل
باتجاه مسار التفاوض مع الفلسطينيين بشان
هذه المسائل هذا الامر سوف يتطلب تغييرا
عارما سياسيا في الداخل الاسرائيلي يؤمن
فيه هذا المجتمع الاسرائيلي ان السلام هو
ما يريده عوضا عن الحرب والتوتر في ظل كل
ما قلناه منذ بدايه البرنامج سيد بلال
الشوبكي كيف تتوقع ان تتم صياغه الموقف
النهائي الاسرائيلي خاصه ونحن ننتظر
اجتماع مجلس الحرب
الليله كما هو العاده في يعني جلسات سابقه
لمجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي لن يخرجوا بمساله
يعني حاسمه قاطعه وانما ستكون الامور
قابله للتاويل مع صياغه اكثر تشددا في
الملا في الرد على الملاحظات المقدمه من
حركه حماس لانه جزء من الرغبه الاسرائيليه
الان هي اظهار ان يعني او اثبات ما قدموه
مرارا على ان اليد العليا في هذه المواجهه
هي لاسرائيل وبالتالي في المفاوضات لابد
ان تكون لها اليد العليا على الاقل ل يعني
يلاحقوا التصريحات التي قدموها بشان اهميه
العمليه العسكريه وانها قد تؤدي الى تليين
موقف حركه حماس والفصائل الفلسطينيه قاطبه
ولذلك نتوقع ان يكون هناك رفض لكثير من
الملاحظات التي قدمت من حركه حماس وربما
لا يشار الى ذلك بالتفصيل على ان يترك
الامر للطرح من قبل الوسطاء لكن دعنا نشير
هنا الى ان الذي يعني يصنع القرار في كل
هذه القضايا ليس فقط المستويات السياسيه
في اسرائيل نحن نتحدث عن دوله ما زالت
فيها بعض المؤسسات عميقه جدا ونافذه وحين
نقول ان هذه المقترحات قد صيغت ب مشاركه
الموساد والشباك الاسرائيلي وحين نتتبع
بعض الاخبار حول تصريحات او يعني رسائل
الشباك الاسرائيلي على وجه الخصوص وتحديدا
فيما يتعلق بالضفه الغربيه كلها تشير الى
ان المؤسسه الامنيه او المؤسستان
الامنيتريكس والشباك ميتان ب ان يكون هناك
دفع باتجاه المفاوضات وان لا يتم اغلاق
الباب بشكل كامل شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور
بلال الشوبكي من الخليل شكرا ايضا لضيفنا
من واشنطن تشارلز دان بهذا مشاهدينا
الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد غدا باذن الله
الثامنه والنص بتوقيت مكه المكرمه